merci merci aussi mais mettez-vous là
aussi merci en tout cas
prenez Ginola d'être avec nous vous êtes
le fils d'Angèle merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui on est fabrique j'attendais
manière j'aurais bien voulu qu'elle soit
elle va arriver votre NES elle est sur
le chemin elle va arriver dans un
instant Alicia qui sera là dans quelques
minutes
qui a parlé là
alors René justement moi je veux avoir
votre avis parce que je vous demande de
parler un peu fort parce que j'ai des
problèmes auditifs
déjà première question comment elle va
votre maman
c'est à dire elle va comment elle est là
elle est sortie aujourd'hui elle est
avec ma sœur en bas qui s'occupe d'elle
ses petits-enfants quand même qui
s'occupent d'elle parce que moi je suis
dans le Var et aller à l'étambins donc
c'est beaucoup maniès justement qui va
arriver qui va arriver qui s'occupe bien
de ses papiers et tout et qui a eu qui a
eu un rapport avec la police et tout
quand ça s'est passé comment comment
vous l'avez appris moi je l'ai appris
parce que ma sœur m'a téléphoné en me
disant maman s'est fait agresser et
quand j'ai vu la photo
pas possible quand vous avez vu la photo
elle fait rien là-dedans il y a pas
assez de c'est moi je suis pas
je sais pas trop m'exprimer mais
prenez-moi votre émotion
je vous ai vu tout à l'heure en loge
mais vite tout de suite j'ai besoin de
parler j'ai besoin de m'exprimer moi
votre émotion elle touche tout le monde
là je vous dis on n'a pas besoin de de
longues distances
ils auraient pu prendre le sac à main
sans la frapper vous avez la violence du
cookies le mec dessus mais c'est pas
avoir des couilles des trucs comme ça et
l'autre il filme il filme il filme le
conneries qui font et vous voulez pas
avoir la haine vous que si vous voulez
devant le mec je l'ai tue tous les trois
moi je dis la même chose que vous mais
je vous le dis je voulais dire un truc
je vais en prison j'y vais en prison
volontiers pour ma mère
aussi
de l'argent rien du tout ça c'est sans
arrêt qui a des trucs comme ça
aux parents vous en voulez à qui pardon
j'en voulais aux parents de ces ados
quand même parce que ils sont pas suivi
ces jeunes qui sont vous les voyez à 14
ans ils sont dans la rue là ils traînent
à minuit un truc
attendez vraiment à mon époque ça se
passe pas comme ça à tel-air il fallait
être à la maison et puis c'est tout et
il y avait pas d'agression comme ça on
allait il y avait des bagarres il y
avait des trucs mais pas des trucs comme
ça pour moi
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans quel état
d'esprit il y a pas c'est pas
pardonnable je regrette même que ça soit
des enfants de 14-15 ans mais quand ils
en arrivent à faire des actes comme ça
pour moi pour moi il y a pas de il y a
pas d'excuses il y a pas d'excuse alors
il paraît j'en ai fait dans ma vie des
conneries moi mais des trucs comme ça
jamais allé s'entraîne à des proies
faciles comme ça mais c'est trop facile
il est très sur 15 m pour leur prendre
de l'essai et les trucs il se passe il y
a trop de il y en a trop de trucs
je sais pas qu'est-ce que vous avez dit
la police
la police vous savez ce qu'elle fait
elle les attrape ils ont elle a pas le
temps de les monter au tribunal qui sont
relâchés ces jeunes
mais ils sont relâchés moi je suis des
collègues qui sont dans la police ils
m'ont dit il m'a dit René
on n'est pas arrivé on n'est pas
redescendu au poste ils sont dehors
parce qu'ils sont mineurs mais en
attendant la responsabilité il apprenne
d'aller frapper une personne
âgée en plus par le pape Luc à une
personne 89 ans qui tient à peine debout
allait y mettre un coup avec les langues
comme millimètre derrière la tête mais
c'est pour la tuer c'est pour la tuer
parce que vous aurez moi quand j'ai vu
les premières photos
j'ai dit ma mère elle est morte elle est
morte
aujourd'hui vous entendez voilà aussi
une qui disait au contraire faut pas se
faire vengeance soi-même c'est ce que
disait Valérie Benaim également
vous attendez quoi là aujourd'hui vous
vous avez envie de faire quoi vous avez
envie vous dites quoi vous envie d'être
auprès de votre maman lui dire voilà
c'est de la réconforter vous allez avoir
peur maintenant chaque fois qu'elle va
bien sûr qu'elle a peur les trucs il y a
le TF1 qui m'a parlé qui ont essayé de
l'appeler parce qu'il voulait la voir on
a dit non laissez-la tranquille à la
pauvre elle n'a pas besoin de trucs elle
sort à peine
il y a mon petit neveu avec
c'est sûr qu'elle a la trouille c'est la
deuxième fois la deuxième fois elle a eu
une petite agression une il y a deux
trois ans de ça c'était deux nanas
qu'elle a vu bon il y a pas eu de il y a
pas eu de coups ils ont pris le truc et
puis le porte le sac et ils ont reposé
plus loin quoi un truc mais bon il y a
pas eu d'agression mais dans le même
immeuble en plus alors il paraît qu'on
vous a proposé de l'argent non ça c'est
pas vrai c'est vrai ça ou pas
entendu ça elle a dit d'ailleurs ma
nièce va le dire bien sûr parce que bon
elle avait perdu parce qu'elle quand
elle est tombée elle a cru qu'elle était
tombée ah oui quand les pompiers sont
arrivés ils ont dit non mais non madame
vous êtes pas tomber on vous a agressé
parce qu'elle était par terre elle avait
perdu un peu la connaissance et elle
pourrait même elle était tombée euh tout
simplement et c'est les pompiers qui ont
dit non non vous avez été agressé après
il y a la police qui est venue après
manière c'est plus au courant que moi
là-dessus parce que c'est ce qui vous a
dit votre maman après une fois que
qu'elle a su qu'elle s'était fait
agresser
quel état d'esprit la pauvre même pas
elle est tellement si vous la connaissez
ma mère elle est tellement connue en bas
elle avait un petit restaurant
elle est bien avec tout le monde c'est
c'est elle en veut même pas elle a dit
quoi non non personnellement elle a dit
ou bien là qui est venue elle a dit
c'est des petits jeunes avant mais ce
truc mais bon on peut pas passer on a
dit on peut pas passer à côté c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible pas pour une
histoire de tout c'est de vengeance ou
quoi c'est que c'est pas que pour ma
mère c'est pour d'autres personnes aussi
qui peuvent se faire agresser donc il
faut que ça bouge il faut que il faut
que ça monte le plus haut possible
qu'ils aient qui est quand même plus de
de
fermeté ou ou je sais pas mais il faut
faire quelque chose il y a pas possible
c'est quoi votre message
vous voudriez quoi en fait mais moi je
voudrais que quand même soyez que j'ai
une qui soit puni mais vraiment puni pas
qu'il soit relâché du jour au lendemain
comme ils ont mais qui est quand même
une
d'ailleurs le j'approuve je voudrais
remercier le maire de Cannes bien sûr
et sur le coup de la colère il a dit
comme moi que si il les avait sur la
main et il y en a qui sont pas d'accord
avec eux les gens qui sont choqués par
cette phrase comme aussi qu'est-ce que
vous leur dites
je sais plus quoi dire
j'ai tellement mal
je suis tellement fâché à l'intérieur
des trucs
pas moi comment réagir à des trucs comme
ça c'est pas possible il y en a qui
ferme les yeux qui disent c'est pas
grave c'est bon c'est pas possible
c'est sûr c'est facile à dire quand
c'est pas sa mère
on se le prend derrière à la tronche et
puis
voilà quoi donc il faut il faut que il
faut que le président ou un truc qui
fasse quelque chose pour ces trucs là
qu'ils aient qu'ils aient je sais pas
moi qui soit qui trouve une sanction
quand même
vous savez René vous savez vous auriez
envie de parler aux parents de de ces
agresseurs
je vais leur dire qu'ils ont des enfants
ils savent pas s'en occuper et qui font
des enfants ou alors ils font des
enfants pour toucher les pour toucher
les tous les aides qu'ils ont et puis
passe en occuper après c'est tout
qu'est-ce que je voulais vous dire
je voulais voyez sont à la rue ils sont
à minuit vous les voyez trainer dans les
rues vous allez détruire
pour les laisser traîner comme ça dans
la rue il faut s'en occuper des petits
cantons les prendre Daniel et parce que
aussi a dit quelque chose tout à l'heure
en disant mais moi je trouve que c'est
du mépris par tous les parents qui
parfois même des mères célibataires qui
arrivent très bien à élever leurs
enfants avec même très peu de moyens
donc ça c'est un mépris je suis désolé
pas toujours une question parce que il y
a des fils de riches qui font des
conneries aussi bien sûr donc c'est pas
une question de c'est bon d'excuser les
les parents qui n'auraient pas de moyens
et moi ce que je dirais à ceux qui sont
contre cette phrase et qui ont été
choqués c'est attendant de voir ce que
vont avoir ces gamins et est-ce que vous
pensez la vraie question je sais est-ce
que vous pensez que des enfants de 14
ans qui ont fait ça sont récupérables ça
c'est la vraie question pour moi
on n'est pas dans un débat le témoignage
de René et Alicia qui nous a rejoint
Alicia vous êtes la petite fille
d'Angèle vous occupez même allez mettre
en prison tout ça c'est pas non plus la
solution alors attendez chez le maire de
chez le maire de Cannes s'il vous plaît
j'ai David Lisnard qui m'appelle en
direct David qui est là qui m'appelle on
dirait qu'il doit nous regarder
bonsoir bonsoir David bonsoir ça va bien
David vous devez nous regarder nous
sommes en direct de vous
appeler
[Musique]
je lui demande bien sûr en saluant
et toute votre équipe
sur
que vous avez rappelé de ma part elle
est en réponse à un internaute qui me
disait Monsieur le Maire on vous a pas
entendu sur ce dossier et donc c'est le
cinquième tweet de il y a 4 trucs qui
précède
dès qu'on a eu des images
on a grâce à un très très
bon transmis des coordonnées la police
nationale on sait bien encore donné quel
polic Ier les trois gamins donc
celui
qui lui parce qu'il y a une autre vidéo
pas celle-là ça c'est la vidéo la
surveillance mais on entend le gamin et
commenter la chute de la victime donc on
était interpellés
le bon équilibre entre et ne pas
apparaître comme récupérer
quelque chose
c'est
rappeler à action humaine
ment et je confirme je l'assume
calmement que si
on prend la mer
mes enfants
[Musique]
et de la loi du talion au personnel la
preuve c'est que dans ce que j'ai écrit
je dis
horizon je dis pas que chacun règle ses
comptes et on le laisse faire
on sera en prison mais j'assumerai mon
inconnu
de citoyens quand on est élu et de
toujours rappeler
que la viande c'est un autre sujet
parmi ce que j'en pense mais je crois
que c'est facile à comprendre et puis
ensuite
[Musique]
règle
ment de personnel
étant
[Musique]
touche la mer là je voulais juste vous
dire ça merci
il s'agit surtout pas de faire une
apologie du règlement personnel
malheureusement beaucoup trop mais à un
moment donné je suis venu
avant d'être élu je serai pas été après
avoir été je suis un être humain et
c'est pas tombé dans la facilité de le
dire c'est tout simplement une réalité
voilà je veux pas vous merci beaucoup
David merci en tout cas
merci vous aussi merci
elle est très résistante elle est sortie
aujourd'hui de l'hôpital merci David
merci de nous avoir appelé merci
beaucoup David merci merci c'était David
Lisnard de canne donc qui nous appelle
en direct c'était pas du tout prévu donc
il nous regardait apparemment voilà où
son équipe a dû lui dire nous sommes
également avec Alicia Alicia de songeur
petite fille d'Angèle nièce donc de de
René vous vous êtes vous étiez où au
moment de l'agression au travail où vous
apprenez ça commence et si vous êtes
très proche de votre grand-mère c'est
comme votre mère je sais donc là c'est
comme René c'est comme vous vous éclatez
en sanglot vous non même pas c'est
l'adrénaline du coup je vais à sa
résidence d'accord et là on vous raconte
ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
qu'il faut que je retourne voir le poste
parce que pour voir les vidéos il faut
que je sois accompagné de la police quoi
alors on va revoir le témoignage de la
de la maman de la maman René qui a parlé
cet après-midi sur BFM c'est vrai voilà
c'est vrai que c'est elle est tellement
touchante regarde
les pompiers mais je sais pas et c'est
là les pompiers qui suis tombé les
pompiers me dis donc j'ai rien fait moi
ce jeune ils étaient trois je sais pas
pourquoi bon je sais pas trop en colère
parce que est-ce que c'est leur faute
votre parent c'est pas son jeu avec 15
ans
[Musique]
voilà quand on la voit on a envie on a
envie de la serrer dans nos bras c'est
vrai qu'on
chante
elle est tellement touchante
est gentil dans le meilleur des mondes
et quoi est-ce que est-ce que vous aviez
une colère comme comme Rony quand vous
avez appris ça pas du tout parce que
René on le voit là il nous a dit oui
mais j'aimerais que ça fasse plus bouger
en fait c'est à dire en fait on commence
jeune quoi des enfants c'est jeune quoi
14 ans c'est jeune mais vous avez envie
de leur dire quoi est-ce que vous avez
jamais envoyé une solution
à trouver où je suis pas pour la prison
donc je vais pas vous parler de prison
mais peut-être il faut les mettre dans
des camps peut-être je sais pas mais
pourquoi mais regarde trop le jeu vidéo
je sais pas parce que les prisons pour
moi
de trouver une solution pour d'autres
personnes pour nous c'est fait c'est
aujourd'hui vous allez vous allez rester
auprès de votre maman vous allez la
retrouver oui bien sûr on va la prendre
chez nous on va pas la laisser chez elle
est-ce que vous vous allez aller voir
les parents mais j'ai pas envie
même pas pour leur dire voilà c'est un
autre venir
votre maman qui va venir ni s'excuser et
d'abord on en veut pas des excuses moi
personnellement mais pas du tout ils ont
pas essayé d'aller la voir qui soit mal
à l'aise quand ils sortent c'est pour ça
que on est vraiment pas de nouvelles
aucune nouvelle zéro ce qui dit c'est
pas vrai zéro zéro et puis il y a pas
aucun sentiment de regret de la part de
ces jeunes aussi qui qui ont dit quoi
ils ont quand même nier pendant 24
heures voire 48 heures aussi les gens
qui les ont couvés à donner des faux
témoignages donc ils ont été faux alibi
ça pour moi
je sais pas si leur famille proche ou
après moi je suis pas pour ne pas une
nouvelle si si vous appelez vous leur
diriez quoi les parents j'ai pas envie
de les avoir en fait d'accord voilà moi
non plus
sauver leur gosse de cette société parce
que dans 5 ans ils font quoi ils
plantent les gens parce qu'on en
étiquette
je veux pas savoir qui c'est je ne veux
pas les voir parce que pour moi c'est
pas des chez des parents qui sont déjà
et puis pour moi ils sont pas
intéressants ils sont pas intéressant
parce que je sais même pas si je sais
même pas si les jeunes les jeunes qui
ont fait le l'attentat ils ont un regret
d'avoir fait ce qu'ils ont ils ont fait
ce que dit Alicia ils n'ont pas de
regrets j'aurais bien voulu avoir une
réponse là-dessus ils ont mis longtemps
quand ils ont été devant les policiers à
reconnaître leur culpabilité ils ont mis
longtemps au début tellement la télé 14
ans oui on est chez nous tous ils ont
reconnu finalement d'ailleurs ils seront
jugés le 30 novembre il risque la prison
très franchement risque la moitié de la
peine encore eu par un donc il risque
trois ans et demi de prison possible
c'est vrai est-ce que ça c'est une peine
qui vous semblerait satisfaisante
moi j'ai peur qu'elle ait un contrecoup
en fait bien sûr
que ça fasse comme ce monsieur
j'ai pensé la même chose j'ai même pensé
à aller mal au cœur j'ai pensé à vie en
passant votre maman c'est pour ça qu'on
aime 50 prisons vous soyez très présent
avec je crois là vraiment peu de de faut
être honnête 90 ans donc autant qu'elle
est pas ce correctement donc ni l'argent
ni les excuses ni l'enfermement il faut
soigner ses enfants là ce qu'ils ont ces
enfants et à commencer aussi juste pour
soigner il faut que la société elle
trouve quelque chose pour soigner ces
gosses qui commencent à 3h30 si prenez 3
ans et demi de prison René est-ce que
pour vous ce serait une peine assez
assez forte donc il se fasse
moi je m'en fous de la peine je veux
vraiment que ça serve pour ses autres
enfants qui se sent comme ça et qui te
donne
est-ce qu'après avoir fait ce peine ce
qui n'est jamais de la vie ils sont
récupérés ces jeunes ou est-ce qu'ils
vont empirer il va avoir encore plus la
haine j'en sais rien c'est la haine
quand même quelle est la solution parce
que quand tu arrives à des points comme
ça quand même ils sont ils sont vraiment
voilà
j'appelle pas ça de la délinquant c'est
de la violence quoi de la délinquance la
délinquance elle a toujours eu ça c'est
de la violence
vous me donnez votre sac ou pas prenez
le sac je vais c'est pour tuer les gens
qui prend c'est c'est ça qui vous a plu
le jeune il est il est baraqué
et ils l'ont suivi ils l'ont suivi
alors on va appeler l'effet pour ceux
qui nous rejoignent alors c'était
l'année dernière à 12h20 votre maman
donc rentre chez elle de course et puis
elle est agressée par derrière un coup
de poing à la tempe par un jeune donc de
14 de 14 ans il y en a un autre qui
filme et il y en a un qui lui vole son
sac pour quelques dizaines d'euros c'est
même pas 30 €, c'est ça
et elle est très choquée heureusement il
y a le gardien de la résidence qui est
là pour 30 euros 30 euros
la vidéo surveillance et le lendemain la
famille de celui qui a porté les coups
le conduit au commissariat et puis les
deux autres sont interpellés dans la
foulée c'est la famille tous les cadeaux
voilà le conduit au commissariat où il
est interpellé et puis ils finissent par
reconnaître leur culpabilité ils sont
j'ai le 30 novembre par un tribunal pour
enfants et là ils sont placés dans des
centres fermés 3 villes différentes pour
pas qu'ils aient de contacts
et pourtant moi j'ai entendu dire je
sais pas sur quoi qui pouvait sortir
comme il voulait
c'est un centre fermé alors
qu'ils sont fiers pour eux c'est un
exploit qui peut le faire
pour dire voilà nous c'est on revendique
ça c'est une sorte de revendication de
filmer pour montrer après
vous vous avez fait quoi etc les
couilles donc évidemment aucune excuse à
attendre de ce genre de personne prenez
et Alicia est-ce que vous avez peur pour
votre maman et votre grand-mère
aujourd'hui peur pour sa santé oui et
pour la pour la suite vous avez la suite
elle s'est rendu compte maintenant de ce
qui s'est passé
c'est pour ça que je voulais demander
qu'on la fasse déménager dans un truc
moi je voulais que le mode d'un peu à la
maison moi mais elle veut pas monter
elle veut pas avancer
avec nous à la campagne
et elle veut pas pour le moment elle a
dit je monterai plus tard
ne veut et Ali il y a eu le contrecoup
après son agression les décédé peu de
temps après
exceptionnel qu'est-ce que vous avez
envie de leur dire ce que vous avez vécu
un moment dramatique et allié il est
parti malheureusement après qu'est-ce
que vous avez envie de leur dire
aujourd'hui
en fait parce qu'on est toujours dans
l'émotion jusqu'à maintenant ça je pense
que ça partira pas après bon quand le
calme revient on réagit d'être plus la
même façon mais après comme j'ai dit
c'est sûr que sur le moment les mecs ils
sont là devant c'est bon moi je vous
remets les choses au clair moi ces
enfants là c'est la même chose que vous
je pense la même chose si j'avais été là
et ainsi de suite sauf que là on parlait
juste d'un maire qui représente quand
même l'autorité
j'ai pas aimé son explication moi j'ai
adoré son expérience
avec quelqu'un l'enfant de quelqu'un
chaque personne
je vais tout le monde c'est comme ça je
vais vous dire la vérité ça fait des
années qu'on est dans des discours
langue de bois des politiques ça fait
des années et on voit bien que ça ne
marche pas c'est pour une fois qu'on a
un mec qui parle avec ses tripes qui n'a
pas dit faites-vous justice vous-même
c'est pas du tout ce qu'il veut
aujourd'hui
on a envie d'avoir des politiques qui
nous ressemblent aussi mais voilà alors
oui bien sûr il veut pas qu'on soit hors
la loi il veut pas qu'on se fasse juste
ici soi-même mais à un moment on lui a
posé une question sur Twitter et envoyer
la réponse parce que c'est un homme
avant d'être un élu c'est ce qu'il a dit
un homme s'entend pas un enfant de 14
ans de 90 ans je comprends pas pourquoi
ça vous choque c'est des artistes qui se
font agresser ça bouge plus vite quand
même
non là ça fait énormément parler
beaucoup plus et
là il y a une émotion considérable alors
il y a une émotion considérable
à ça j'espère que ça fera évoluer les
choses moi je suis très contente
je suis très content
on m'a dit que je pouvais dire ce que je
voulais je le dis hein
d'ailleurs si vous voudriez dire ce soir
voilà je vous laisse carte blanche
qu'est-ce que vous voudriez dire sur ce
qui s'est passé en sortant là oui demain
on va en voir des grosses pages hein
franchement des grosses pages moi je
suis contente vous avez des grosses pas
toujours content
de travailler j'avais peu d'espoir parce
que à la base il y a personne quand même
hein c'est super
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que vous avez envie de dire de
nous dire ce soir déjà j'espère qu'elle
nous regarde on lui fait un énorme bisou
qu'est-ce que vous avez envie de dire un
à ces agresseurs et de à votre maman
c'est pour moi c'est des petits cons
on voudrait juste que ça puisse
créer demain je serai content
alors je rappelle que c'est le c'est le
fils de la victime et pour un fils c'est
vrai que
oui pardon si je pense qu'il dit mais
c'est pas choquant ce qu'il dit c'est
choquant ce qui se passe effectivement
extrêmement touché parce
qu'effectivement au-delà des gens de 14
ans on y rajoute de la lâcheté et puis
effectivement ce qui est très important
de ce que vous avez dit mais je vous
laisse la parole c'est que on va
aujourd'hui on va au-delà de l'agression
on est si il y a une haine il y a une
haine
bien sûr